if we're alive and more or less
functioning if we're capable of taking
joy in things occasionally if we can be
kind and grateful to others if we're not
addicted or very drawn to killing
ourselves then it's likely that someone
somewhere early on loved us very much
they may live quite far away from us now
they might share none of our interests
and could in many ways be a little
boring to spend time with and yet we
will continue to be deeply loyal to them
and know in our hearts that we owe them
everything when we say that someone
loved us what we're really referring to
is the acquisition of a set of skills
these were not transferred in any formal
way we imbibed them in the ordinary
bustle of daily life it might have been
in the kitchen on a walk out in the
woods so at night time in the bedroom
after a story it would have been easy to
miss what was really going on the vital
nectar that was being imparted all the
life-sustaining goodness we received
when it looked like it was just another
conversation about homework or the plans
for the weekend but in the course of
being loved
we got an encyclopedic emotional
education nevertheless in which some of
the following was learned endurance
sometimes it all looked very bad indeed
we were in a state soaked in tears or
read with fury
we felt the world was coming apart and
that we would not survive but they kept
the tragedy at bay until we could
breathe calmly once again they may not
have had all the answers but they
promised us and they were right that a
few would eventually emerge they held us
through the night and guaranteed that
there would be a dawn and ever since
then it's become just a little easier to
keep catastrophic dread at bay self love
they lent us a sense that we were of
value to them and therefore could one
day be to ourselves as well if we made
something or had an idea we could share
it with them and though it wasn't
perhaps entirely accomplished already
they
were guided by our underlying intentions
and promise when we entered the kitchen
not every time but enough times to form
a protective layer over our ego they
looked up and lit up they might have had
a name for us little champion button
chop saw
sweet sheep at one point in adolescence
we certainly didn't want that sort of
name used anymore and it would be
mortifying if colleagues near it today
but it remains a secret symbol of an
emotional bedrock upon which all our
later poise and confidence was able to
emerge forgiveness at points we did
something very wrong we forgot a book we
scratched a table we were nasty to
someone who were exploded in fury the
punishment could have been very strong
and yet it wasn't they came up with
reasons that cast our misdeeds in a
generous light we were tired everyone
does that sort of thing no one is
perfect
they taught us about mercy towards
others and ourselves they let us know
that we would not have to be perfect to
deserve to exist
patience we didn't master much
immediately it took us a while to get
long division it was ages till we found
our way with the piano or learnt to make
biscuits but they didn't shout or morkul
get irritated they taught us the art of
waiting to look good could emerge they
didn't demand immediate results and so
spared us the need to panic or bluster
our way through life repair there were
sometimes some pretty bad scenes they
said nasty things and we did too we felt
we hated them a lot sometimes but they
stuck around they took the anger and
thereby taught us about repair how
things can go very wrong and yet can be
fixed
our resilient people can be how many
second chances there are when love is
involved with some of these lessons and
more we grew up into people who could be
kind to ourselves tolerant of our faults
sympathetic to others and capable of
keeping going we weren't just loved we
got an education
presence we can feel every time we can
care for someone else address a kind
word to ourselves or feel strong enough
to face a difficult tomorrow
we hope you enjoyed this film for more
from the School of Life you can
subscribe to our channel and take a look
at our range of products on our website
you